foreign  a Washington woman receives thousands of  dollars in a settlement after her August  2021 arrest in the city of Spokane  Spokane police say Erica Prince Simmons  was arrested on August 7 2021 on charges  of Suspicion of trespassing at the time  officers in the area were responding to  reports of an altercation at a nearby  bar Prince Simmons was recording the  police activity on her phone okay do you  want her to have your phone or do you  want to keep it I would love to keep it  okay she wants to keep it charges  against Prince Simmons were later  dropped she filed suit against the city  and county for a First Amendment  violation in all she received a payout  of more than 57 thousand dollars  so unnecessary  the city of Spokane admitted no fault in  the settlement for the latest  developments in this story and alting's  True Crime stay with long crime Network  I'm Sierra Gillespie